all right we are 15 minutes in
and oh it doesn't
doesn't look that compelling i'll be
[Music]
[Applause]
honest
it's the holidays and there is nothing
that that makes me want to do more than
machine learning
today i'm going to build a machine
learning model that will analyze recipes
and then dream up an entirely new recipe
that i'll bake and eat right before you
hear today
and to make the project a little bit
sweeter i'll add just a sprinkle of
model explainability so we understand
why our model is making the predictions
that it is i'll be joined by sarah
robinson
sarah is an ai expert and baking
extraordinaire who works with me at
google hey sarah
hey dale thanks for having me i heard
that a couple of months ago
you used a machine learning model to
come up with a new recipe that you baked
can you tell me about that
so i've been baking a ton over the past
few months and after following a lot of
recipes i started to notice that
a lot of baking recipes follow a pattern
so i started to wonder since machine
learning is all about finding patterns
and data
could i build a machine learning model
to predict what i'm making given a list
of ingredient amounts
so i built a model to predict whether a
recipe was a bread
cake or a cookie so we're gonna do
exactly the same thing here today
we'll build a model that takes a list of
ingredients and then predicts
bread cake or cookie and then we're
gonna use that core model to come up
with new recipes that we'll bake
right awesome let's get started so step
one
is to collect a data set of cookies cake
and bread recipes
we gathered about 700 recipes next we
have to do a bit of data preprocessing
for example there's a lot of consensus
that banana bread and pumpkin bread
are actually cakes even paul hollywood
agrees
so we had to move the banana and pumpkin
breads from the bread category
into the cake category next we slimmed
down the recipes to just their core
ingredients like flour eggs butter sugar
and a couple more
we also converted all of our ingredient
amounts from cups and sticks and
teaspoons and tablespoons into one
single measurement unit
we use ounces okay so here are all of my
recipes they're converted into ounces
i'm cleaned up and labeled in a google
sheet
to build my model i'm going to use a
tool in google cloud called automl
tables which is a no code tool for
building machine learning models to
analyze tabular data
like spreadsheets or databases okay i'm
opening up tables
and i'll import my data from that csv i
just showed you
i have to select the bucket where i want
data to be stored and it'll take a
second to import
when it's done i can click on my new
data set and as you can see a couple of
stats about the data are automatically
generated
like whether certain columns are missing
values and also this useful field
correlation with target which says in
isolation how good is each of these
columns that predicting whether or not
something is cake bread or cookie
i've also selected a target field which
is what we're trying to predict which is
in this case type
that i've already selected to train a
model i'll click the train model button
name my model say how long i want it to
train for
specify which columns i want to include
i don't want to use the name of the
recipe or urls or ids or anything like
that
and then i click train model and wait
this part could take a couple of hours
when my model is done training i can see
how well it did in the evaluate model
tab
here i can see lots of stats on model
accuracy and if i scroll down to the
confusion matrix i can also see how
often my model correctly predicted
recipes
so it was most accurate for bread which
is labeled correctly 93
of the time and a little less accurate
for cookies which it confused for cake
21
of the time when i'm ready to use my
model i can hop into the test and use
tab and here i can make predictions
right from within the ui
so i can fill in the values for a cake
recipe
click predict and boom the model thinks
this is cake which is correct
so sarah was able to build a model that
takes a recipe and then predicts cookie
cake
or bread but the inquisitive baker might
want to know what is it that makes a
cookie a cookie
what gives it that chewy crunchy
property that cookiness if you will
and what makes bread fluffy and cake
spongy in other words we want a model
that not just makes a prediction but
also
explains what ingredients it was looking
at when it made that prediction and
that's called model explainability
right we want to understand how
important each ingredient is to the
model when it's deciding whether
something is a bread
a cookie or a cake i can take a look at
feature
importance which tells me how important
different ingredients are to the overall
model's predictions
so in this case butter sugar and yeast
we're really good at helping
differentiate the baked goods
now even though butter might be
important to the overall model it might
be that different ingredients matter
more depending on the recipe
so if i go into the test and use tab i'm
going to put in a cake recipe
and then i'll hit this generate feature
importance box
hit predict and then i'll be able to see
how ingredients matter for a specific
recipe
here egg and fat got the highest future
important scores so we can assume that
they're the most important thing the
model was looking at when it decided
that this was a cake
okay so now i'm gonna try something
really radical i'm gonna bake not a
cookie
or a cake but something that our model
deems to be a split between the two
a cakey if you will and i'm gonna bake
something that's a half bread
half cookie i'm gonna call it a breaky
to find a breaky recipe
i adjusted the ingredients in the model
ui until our model predicted that our
recipe was about
equal parts cookie and bread same for
dale's cakey
all right sarah are you ready to bake
yes let's do it on your marks
get set bake
[Music]
none of my training prepared me for this
right here's the thank you
[Music]
good luck little cake cookie kiki
here is what we've got
okay i guess i'll try to pry it from the
pan
it does taste like a cookie but it is
like a little bit more airy
i can't tell if it's cooked all the way
[Music]
did not work exactly the way i had
poked it might work this is actually
pretty good
[Music]
okay it's kind of nasty so yeah i guess
it's a success
i wonder if i put i put the right amount
of flour or double the amount of flour
so i think i kind of flubbed that recipe
something with the flour
but sarah then went back and baked it
herself and her kiki came out just fine
so i guess we'll have to attribute that
to human error
if you want to know the details of this
project and steal our recipes make sure
you check out the blog post linked below
happy holidays and see you next year
you